there was some kind of chemistry between
us that we absolutely hadn't counted on
did you display an early talent for for
singing awful I didn't actually I got
thrown out of the choir
it's a ridiculous situation to sign a
contract when you're 18 years old and be
held to it for your entire professional
career I used to get really really
paranoid and after every show I'd have
to go straight back to hotel and talk to
no one
he was an English singer songwriter
record producer who rose to prominence
for his part in the duo Wham he's best
known for his work in the 80s and 90s
including hit singles last Christmas and
wake me up before you go-go he sold over
100 million records worldwide he's
George Michael and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success rule number two
is our personal favorite and I'm curious
to figure out which one you guys like
the best and as always as George is
talking if he says something that really
resonates with you please leave it in
the comments below and put quotes around
it so other people can be inspired as
well enjoy
[Music]
the first mention of George Michael in
my life was by Mark Dean who ran this
little label called inner vision and he
said I've signed an act that you're
going to love and they're going to be
huge and they're called
Wham and I said they're called Wham
he said yes they're called Wham there
was starting to get noticed on the UK
music scene but what was it about Wham
that made them stand out from the
competition I think to be honest with
you great songs and you know such a
formula that we didn't realize we had
you know these two young boys doing this
kind of Butch Cassidy and Sundance thing
but in a very kind of camp way and there
I think there was something about the
fact that it was all very obvious that
our relationship as friends was real
there was some kind of chemistry between
us that we absolutely hadn't counted on
you know but the world seemed to see
pretty quickly what about the the the
the business of being what you are now
they had the musician the songwriter I
mean did you did you display an early
talent for singing awful I didn't
actually I got thrown out of the choir
video I was thrown out of the choir for
I think as far as I know it was for
talking and and I always remember my dad
used to say to me you know because I
used to say dad that when I was like you
know 16 17 18 and my dad was threatened
to throw me out the house if I didn't
get job within a certain amount of time
so obviously I went out and got jobs but
I was saying I want to be a singer you
know I think I'm going to be rich and
famous and he would say you know
everybody wants to be a pop sing
everybody was I said and I would say no
dad everybody wants to be a pop singer
when they're 12 you know when they're 12
this is my whole life this is what I
want to do but um but but I've lost my
train of thought
region famous your ambition I mean was
that oh I think I had two very very
strong ambitions and they've always
fought against one another always and
one was a passion for music and an
ability to communicate through music and
really a sense of purpose through music
and two was this desire to be an
enriched and famous he's not right
because actually rich never came into it
I actually realized about six months ago
someone put a question to me and
actually realized that at no point
during my early life when I was in all
my ambitions or even when III started to
to realize my ambitions at no point did
I ever occur to me but one of the
byproducts of this would be that I could
buy whatever I wanted or you know live
in a big house have a flashy car all the
things that are very pleasant you know
but it really hadn't occurred to me it
never occurred to me so I didn't want to
be rich I wanted to just wanted to be
filthily famous I signed that contract
and I understand the promise of sanctity
of contract but it's such a ridiculous
such a ridiculous situation firstly you
are almost always signing people in a
very vulnerable position I mean I
definitely was in a very informal person
the first contract audios great exactly
I was at the age of 18 and many bands
assigned that young summer signed a
little older but whenever they're signed
they're desperate whenever they're
signed they think it's going to be their
only chance you know but more
importantly than the other than the the
balance of that situation which is very
unfair is the fact that there isn't one
other industry that operates on this
basis if I were an author and I fell out
with my record company in the way that I
have the worst I would have to endure
was the fact that I would have to that
they would have the first option on my
next book so during that two books
it's a ridiculous situation to sign a
contract when you're 18 years old and be
held to it for your entire professional
career why why would any court uphold
that situation the judge seems to have
found in my case that I reaffirmed this
contract at all at the given points of
my renegotiations but did I really have
any choice the choice that I had was to
go along with that length of term or to
do what I've done now which has been an
incredibly difficult process the abiding
fact obviously for the judge was that
you had voluntarily and with expert
advice sign these contracts are you
talking about the first contract really
true yes I mean I mean that I mean that
on the one hand as we see your quandary
but I mean for him the abiding fact and
was and I guess for many people was that
you did sign them on balance you decided
it's better to sign and they're not and
that's why you're left with the
consequences I think it but I think
that's a very very odd position to take
I think that in all honesty I think that
there is more to consider in this case
than my situation I mean from my point
of view I really honestly do not expect
the public to have any great sympathy
for a man who's very wealthy you know
I'm in good health I'm very wealthy and
I have a lot of public support and I
completely accept that I'm not looking
for public sympathy I just don't believe
that if you are wealthy that your
principles are supposed to be a null and
void that you that you're not supposed
to fight for for what for your
principles all artists except that have
accepted for years and years that they
get a considerably small piece of the
pie considering that they are the raw
product and people go out and buy what
they give but I have to be honest it's
never been a big problem for me being
paid less than other artists as has
always been a problem for me in terms of
pride in terms of money always making
I'm lucky enough to be one of the people
that sells enough records that I don't
care I mean I have
very good lifestyle I'm very wealthy I
would also have to add I'm nowhere near
as wealthy as the tabloid press would
let you believe but I'm perfectly happy
with the money I've got and they say 80
million and they say 80 million let's
just say it's let's just call it a
fraction all right but it's writing more
than a half between aha I'm not telling
you though I wouldn't never caught that
yeah and I telling you that
but let me put it this way I think I've
got something to complain about simply
because in principle it's wrong the end
result is that I'm still a very wealthy
man so really I can understand people
thinking he should shut its mouth but
the principle is wrong and this case is
has decided or it's not over yet as I
emphasized it's not over yet but this
case will decide the future of all our
of all artists in my position with times
in the last five six years that I was
very tempted to just say you know what
forget it this is too difficult you're
not going to come up with the album that
you need and you're and you're driving
yourself crazy with it and I was and I
was and of course on top of that I was
getting quite a kicking from the press
so at that point in my life with with so
much going on emotionally washing you
know being kicked about by that by the
media and the press and the industry
almost wishing that instead of almost
wishing that my career was over I just
was I was almost ready to give up but
part of my motivation a very strong part
of my motivation to keep going was I
always knew how terrible it would look
to young gay kids that were worried
about coming out not that they
necessarily see a great parallel with a
you know someone who was outed when they
were 35 but I think it is a very it
would look it would be a horrible way to
leave my career to leave people thinking
that my sexuality took away my market
because I just knew that wasn't true and
I felt a kind of responsibility not only
to myself but to young gay people to say
look I because I was felt absolutely
sure that my market hadn't left me so I
felt it really important to say look it
is not damaging if you are if you have
ability it is not damaging to add to
come the confidence to come out and that
in certain parts of life it really
doesn't matter anymore in certain
careers it really doesn't matter anymore
and I think just the success of the
record this time around and I hope it's
continued success will alleviate that
perception you know I'm looking forward
to getting more and more comfortable
with that my voice getting stronger and
stronger as as the tour goes on you know
what do you do to prevent it from from
nothing you see luck you're just lucky
I'm just lucky I mean I I you know I I
have lozenges that I sucked the whole
day out paranoia but no really I since I
learned to relax about it
I found it much easier actually I used
to get really really paranoid and after
every show I'd have to go straight back
to the hotel and talk to no one you know
and it's so dull and so boring and
actually led to more throat problems
because of the anxiety but I'm much more
relaxed about it now and my voice seems
to be fine so and I feel ready to do it
and it also feels very honest you know
it feels very honest um I would not be
ready to come out and do another three
years of a greatest hits tour and even
though there are some of my greatest
quite a few of my greatest hits in this
it's something completely different you
know and that's what I need right now
you know I don't want as I said I don't
really interested in repeating
experiences again and again and I like
to challenge myself to improve as a
vocalist and believe me singing with an
orchestra is one way to do it really so
what challenges do you see lie ahead ah
well that well the dance album is a
challenge I think it will be a challenge
with the media but but the challenge of
this tour really is to see what kind of
a singer I can be by the end of it by
Christmas I think I'll see just what the
percent my potential as a singer is at
this point in time you know and I hope
that I'll be a better
than I've ever been you haven't been all
that kindly handled by the critics have
you I mean music physics apply only the
public like it's the usual syndrome but
I mean why why do you think the critics
are inimical to you why do you think
they give you so much yes I think it's
exactly that I think it's because we do
own up to everything that we do we're
very honest about how we market
ourselves we're probably the only band
at the moment who are totally unashamed
of being screamed at and I think it's
like we do everything that everyone else
does only everyone else is very very
subtly camouflaging the ways of selling
themselves and we just think you know
there's no reason that you don't have to
it's not insulting your public to do it
and to tell them you're doing it because
I enjoy it just the same way even
marketing is marketing and an image is
image no one thinks that's really us I'm
gonna deep down I don't think anybody
would think that we're what we portray
ourselves to be in our videos or
anything but because we make it so
obvious that we're mucking about
I think people we like blow other
people's cover and it's it's irritating
to a lot of people
another headline-grabbing move George
announced that his next album patience
will be his last record on sale to the
public and future releases would be
available for free download only well
ask me what I said was it be available
for free or for charitable donation if
people wanted to and the actual truth is
nobody nobody died nobody donated
anything so I kind of kind of withdrawn
the idea as it were I don't I mean what
I've said and what I still believe is
that if in order to make my life work
for me in an industry which is falling
apart I think the things that I want to
say are those things that I still have
to say I don't I think are out of place
now in the medium of pop so I think I
might have to look for other avenues in
which to write um because I'm not who I
was even five years ago you know I got
some brand new ideas now and and and I
want them to be of some use I want to
I've always believed that my creativity
is is is with me for a reason you know
and that they're always wanting to have
a positive effect in life with what you
create is
something that is hard to give up you
know even though it'd be lovely to be
self-indulgent
I do really believe that there's a
reason that I I was given this gift and
it doesn't just have to be in my voice
you know it's about things I want to say
in the breaks of this tour II understand
that you're recording a new album which
is very different from the Symphonica
tour dance music how do you combine the
two well the thing is I'm I'm interested
in the two you know what I'm saying I've
always had I mean I think I'm pretty
well-known for having there being a
fairly even balance in my successes in
terms of ballads and up-tempo songs and
and so that's kept my kind of lyric
writing the lyrics right element of why
do going constantly because I'm working
in my mind on that and this is all much
more about my voice you know so I think
I think my age to be able to have those
two things going on and to know that
they'll both be heard to a degree is
quite remarkable I'm a son you know I'm
thrilled about it to have that kind of
momentum in my own brain at this age you
know I mean obviously you can't come on
a show like this without mention of the
wanking in the toilet thing which one in
the toilet day which one be arrested all
records have that one yeah the one out
worried about and
this time I got caught you
the way you talk about is it your
fantastic sort of unapologetic versus
and you didn't go into hiding you didn't
you know sort of go you know draw the
curtains like that was it the next night
you were out in a restaurant in LA
having dinner
absolutely well I mean what's to
apologize for you know I'm a gay man I'm
at the time I was like 36 years old can
I be if I'm perfectly honest if I'm
perfectly perfectly honest outside of my
career I've had a terrible run of luck
that started about 10 years ago I've
I've I've watched a partner die I've
watched my mother die I went just after
that I had I went to ASEA as a back
surgeon who told me that if I didn't
have two vertebra removed within the
next six months to year that I could
paralyzed so you just learn to have a
different perspective I don't give a
toss if people have a real problem with
me you know having
I have a different perspective on life I
lost a lot of great things but I still
have a lot of incredible things and the
press doesn't really enter into it I
don't care if people never see my face
in the next term you know for the rest
of this century the body of work is safe
now you know if I get hit by bus
tomorrow you know people will remember
what I've done and they'll still enjoy
it you know I'm so lucky I mean people
make brilliant music all the time that
doesn't get played for 20 years and for
some reason I don't mind just sits in
that pocket where it does and such an
incredible thing to to feel that you've
achieved that it's very possible that
pop has had the best out of me that's
going to get even though I want to be
making music til the day I die it's
perfectly possible to say you know 25
years on the charts is pretty good going
and you can't expect to be relevant
forever you know but the body of work
I've done already five albums in 25
years not exactly prolific but I think
pretty good in terms of quality thank
you guys so much for watching I made
this video because my video editor
Christina asked me to thank you for that
Christina so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know what the George State that had the
biggest impact on you and why please
leave it in the comments and I'm going
to join in the discussion finally want
to give a quick chef it's at Wong Union
thank you so much for picking up ten
copies of my book and continuing to
spread the love and gift it into other
people I love the pictures keep them
coming man and I appreciate all the
support so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon